you know i've gotten a chance to meet a
lot of people and be able to call them
friends
uh in the nfl and this is one of them
he's been a regular on the show way back
to our
podcast days always had him on before
the combine and whenever he was able to
before the draft in his uh years as the
general manager from 2008 to
uh just last year for the atlanta
falcons he is thomas dimitrov how are
you friend
rich great to hear your voice and i you
know just so you know
i have to see your face like last year
before the draft i had y'all you know
the background i put you on the screen
so like
i'm a visual person this just connects
us a little bit more
it's very important yeah you know what
and i i'm i look better on the all 22.
i really do you know i agree with you
thomas you know i think this is a
picture from ann arbor okay very good
very good um so let's let's get into
this here thomas because
you are my uh expert
on on what it's like to evaluate talent
and
make a decision certainly a big one atop
the draft with arthur blank
being the guy who owns the team
so walk me through what you think is
going on
with the atlanta falcons and how it
looks with
um with with the new coach and arthur
smith and terry fontenot
uh who uh succeeded you as general
manager there
for arthur blank walk me through what
you this looks like for fans
yeah you know i think um you know arthur
obviously is
is very in tune with what's going on
within the organization
he is uh obviously he's very passionate
about it and his interaction with
um general managers and head coaches you
know is really good it's very astute
and uh there are high expectations on
all sides
as far as communicating regularly and
that is great i
i welcome that i know mike said that and
i know dan quinn did it was a very good
work workable and working relationship
between the management and
and the owner and uh again there are
situations around the league where some
people
prefer not to have that and other people
prefer prefer to have it
i liked it i thought it was really good
you always knew where you stood
you communicated well that's important
that said i'm sure
terry who by the way i'm i'm excited for
i like terry personally
we get along well i have a great deal of
respect for him um
you know and i i i do truly hope that
things work out well there like i want
the best of that organization
have a lot of people that i have a great
deal of regard for
so knowing terry and knowing terry's
personality as i do and i don't know him
that well but knowing arthur's
personality there's just a lot of really
good interaction right now
i don't know arthur smith personally but
what i know of him i think that group is
really communicating well
and they're in the middle of making a
decision as you know quarterback or not
after signing matt ryan i can only
imagine the discussion
so let's get into it a little bit more
so um
who's in the room do you think is rich
mckay in there as well as they go
through it i mean what what what is this
what does it like i said look like for
everyone in the room
how does that work there's no question
uh in my mind
again uh i'm sure it hasn't changed i'm
sure
you know rich is arthur's confidant and
he's arthur's designee i mean
they are you know he's a very important
part of that organization
and he's he's working alongside uh you
know the
of the neophyte general manager and head
coach which i've been there before yes
and i know how important that is
so there's a lot of great discussion
there's film discussion
there's contractual discussion there's
you know draft projection discussions of
course
i mean it's i have always said atlanta
thousands no matter how anyone wanted
perceive it rich
it was a very well thought out
organization art the blanket that home
was not letting it be
anything but that no matter who was in
charge so your best guess right now
thomas dimitrov as
the falcons are going through the do we
take
a quarterback uh not named
uh wilson lawrence and whoever the 49ers
choose
do we take kyle pitts or jamar
chase or penae sewell to either
give ryan a weapon or protect him
or trade out best guess just knowing
again on everything that you have been
there and
done that you've you've made a big trade
to move up for julio jones you've
gone ahead and made big draft choices
for this organization
best guess has arthur blank told
everyone in the room
what he wants for this pick you know
what i don't know if he has
and um you know again are there very
mindful of that of not
overriding of course i would say back to
your first question
and there's there's a lot to choose from
i think at the outset of this year
i thought that they were 100 percent
gonna go quarterback i just really
believe that
it would have been a perfect uh you know
transition
to have a young quarterback come in
there and continue to learn from someone
like matt ryan who i have a great deal
of respect for him
and rich i think he can continue to win
in this league and and i think he
he could win a super bowl you have to
have the right situation around him of
course
but you know with the resigning uh or
redoing of the contract and
and and securing of matt there um
i think they would still do themselves
well by considering a quarterback in
that spot
i really do believe rich that they have
a lot of um
and i say this humbly but i think
there's still a lot of firepower on that
offense
and to add another you know receiver or
something in
in that vein i don't know necessarily if
that
is the most useful uh i know kyle pitts
is not necessarily a receiver and he's a
talented tight end of course
a lot of people would argue to to draft
to tighten that high
you know what would they be thinking no
matter how good he is
and a lot of people thought back in 2011
to trade up for
a receiver of 21 spots i.e julio jones
was
beyond uh ridiculous so you never know
how it plays out
thomas dimitrov former general manager
of the falcons here
on the rich eisen show i i think you you
see what i'm driving at here
is that um is that there's a ton of
voices in the room
and there is an owner who does like to
um
you know give his two cents or know what
is going on as you've already
established
so what can you tell us about the matt
ryan contract and how that might inform
us on
the decision making for this team how
many more years how much
you know how many dollars would it cost
to cut him in certain future years if
they do draft someone or
it is so prohibitive to
cut him that it makes sense to get him
the weapon right now and just try it one
more time with matt ryan
thomas well i think the first thing that
needs to be understood is
when we redid the contracts for both
matt ryan
which was a 30 million dollar plus
contract a year of course
and julio jones 22 plus those deals were
done
uh with the the idea and the vision
of both of those uh players being there
for the rest of their career
it wasn't set up in any way for us to
think that we were going to be trading
they were both pillar players on our you
know on our team and within our
organization within the community
and are still so highly regarded so
there is
a lot of dead money involved in that and
debt money with just cutting to the
chase
basically means if you you know trade or
release a player like that
there's a lot of money i.e you know tens
of millions of dollars plus plus plus
i'll just say that way uh hanging over
the organization's head
no matter what the deal is so um what i
would say
for instance in that situation is the
idea of having a young quarterback come
in there i can't stress enough the
importance of what they
could learn and they you know the
competition in that situation would be
would be valid for sure um it does not
mean within the next couple years that
there could be
could be changes in moves but as it
stands right now
i think matt is a very important part of
this organization going forward
from my perspective uh of course i have
not talked to
you know terry or or arthur uh smith
about that so let's just say
if you if if um they they do
go ahead and get a weapon like pitts or
chase or somebody like that
or somebody knocks on the door and just
falls so head over heels in love with
kyle pitts that
that that terry fontenot receives uh the
godfather offer he cannot refuse
what what would be what is that what is
somebody who has
spent a lot of capital to trade up what
would it
be what would it look like for the
falcons do you think to trade back down
and build for the future by not by
passing up the opportunity to get such a
great a plus
plus weapon for matt ryan right now walk
me through that
well look i i mean you know how it is it
really depends i mean
depends on where they're moving up from
but you know for an
organization and a general manager you
know a
newer general manager a new general
manager and team builder
uh both both terry and arthur
smith in the end would sit down in their
room
and really have a deep really deep
discussion about
you know how far back they would go and
what the trade compensation would be and
if it were
to be you know smart enough and and deep
enough
i.e you know second rounds or first
rounds talked about of course like
legitimate picks that would add to the
strength of building this organization
into a championship caliber organization
they would have to contemplate of course
and they would have to consider
but again it is all it is all no
question about it it is
about you know the money involved uh
money meaning that the compensation
involved the draft picks the money that
it will take as well
there are so many layers to to consider
of course
but there has to be a lot of discussion
and and back to arthur very quickly
because i think this is important
arthur blank though he is a very strong
owner
he knows that he has given the keys to
these gentlemen and i have no doubt my
mind that he is going to let them
devoid of you know besides the
conversation of
if he and rich mckay he's going to let
them make this decision if that's
trading back
it's going to be on them to make the
decision to trade back
so i think in the end in the end there's
going to be
there's probably been a number of people
knocking on the doors
it's just a matter of if it plays out
right and they can find the right person
in that 12 13 14 range to accommodate
what they need to build this team into
what they want to build
so then let's thomas let's just uh put a
button on this part
before i want to ask you a couple
questions outside of the falcons
organization
about this draft uh put a button on it
let's remove the
the the trading out portion of it
because as you point out
it really depends right it depends on
where somebody's coming from and the
compensation that they get that would
create a godfather offer right like
that's that's something that that's
interpretive and
obviously a complete total um
if but situation what would you do what
would you do
okay knowing you just choose from jones
lance and fields or you got pits chase
and sewell
what would you thomas dimitrov if you
were there be counseling for right now
to do with the fourth overall pick
well again this is not me answering for
the atlanta falcons as you well know but
for me right now
as i look at this i think it is a very
important time to seriously consider
you know the the quarterback position
you claim
as an organization or i would claim as a
general manager
to not want to be back in the top five
for many years
and this opportunity doesn't come around
too soon but for trading up 21 plus
spots of course so
which is rare and it may be an
organization once in an organization
uh once in an organization's lifetime
that you would do that so
you have to i think really really
seriously look at it
even having matt there and i think matt
could be a massive
important uh uh positive to have matt
and another quarterback there
working together for years to come so
put your scout hat on which quarterback
do you like
anything you're you're you're not a guy
named uh trevor lawrence
yeah i know that that that that would be
from the jones the mac jones trey lance
justin fields what do you think i mean
those guys are all interesting of course
and
you know there's there's a really cool
home home town
uh element to uh justin fields of course
and
a lot of really interesting parts to his
game and
you know his movement is athleticism and
and what he can do on the field
and uh you know presence so i'm gonna be
really interested to see how he falls
into place there so he's he's he's a guy
that's really interesting of course
thomas dimitrov here in the rich eisen
show just before i let you go thomas
the uh third overall pick as we all know
the 49ers made an aggressive maneuver to
say the least
that caught everyone's attention there
was a three-team deal that included the
eagles and the dolphins also swapping
spots
do you think is it possible the 49ers
made this aggressive move
still not knowing which player
they're gonna choose third overall that
they're just gonna still go through that
jones fields lance evaluation i just
asked you about that they're still
grinding tape on this that they went to
jed york and said this is what we want
to do
we're we we're we're confident in any of
the three but
uh or or do they they just
have the name and they're just playing
it close to the vest what do you think
well you know again knowing kyle and
john lynch and those are two very good
football
team builders and they definitely have
planned a b and c
there's no way you could do that just
counting on one because you really truly
never know
how it's going to play out so i would
say they have their favorite and their
favorite i'm sure is
a very strong favorite believe me but
there are
other favorites along the way that you
would say in the end
what's really important for your
listeners to know when you're sitting in
that draft room
and that very high ranking favor doesn't
work
there is no way you want to be moving up
as you did
and taking another guy with sort of
reluctance in your voice
everyone feels the energy in the room
believe me rich that is
one thing i truly know and and as team
builders you you better make sure that
you have someone that's going to be
really really viable if the number one
idea doesn't work out
because that sets a tone for the whole
season well i guess the number one idea
out of the three wouldn't work out um
only if one of the three like gets hurt
right between now and and and the draft
which is another reason why you play
your cards close to the best because
there's no reason if they do love mac
jones say mac jones the guy
then all of a sudden mac jones gets hurt
and they don't draft him and then
whoever they draft they're like you're
you're now officially known as plan b
right i mean like you can't do that
correct that's exactly right well
and do we truly know it's mac jones i
mean maybe we do maybe
i mean look i know this i mean kyle
having worked with him obviously has a
massive understanding a great
understanding of that system and what he
wants
in that system and that's something that
always stood out in his evaluations
because
he knows what he wants for that system
more than anyone
knows what they want for a system in my
mind and so
you know again it is it's not just him
he and john of course john has a really
good feel of how he wants to build that
team
so you're exactly right but there may be
another guy out there that we all think
it may be mac and it may be someone else
and you i don't know if you were able to
catch uh because i know you've been
traveling
but uh kyle shanahan's press conference
when
when they did meet after the dr after
the trade and he kind of
bristled at everybody in the media
pegging
kirk cousins as his prototypical
quarterback
and that he didn't really want to be
pegged as having anybody as a
prototypical quarterback i mean
if if if you're saying you know matt
why wouldn't matt ryan be his
prototypical quarterback you know i mean
it looked pretty damn good in that game
uh
as we all know so i don't know
what his prototypical quarterback really
is we're just we are just
all assuming out of all three that are
not named lawrence and wilson it is mack
jones
thomas well i think i think the one
thing i say on that the very last thing
is
again stressing kyle's understanding of
the system and what he wants and a guy
who has enough movement to him
who can and keep defenses on their heels
look that's the way it's going the
evolution of this quarterback position
and then you get a guy
out and you know at the chargers in
and who is six six and still moves like
he's six feet like that's pretty amazing
uh given some of the athletes in this
draft at that position
i think it's gonna be really interesting
to see where kyle points his finger
thomas you the man
i really appreciate it um you know i i
i always cherish our chats um and
our streak is still alive you're talking
to me through before the draft this is
great
um i don't know if we have the visual um
but you did put me up on your board and
i appreciate that
so let's just say that this is the
similarity the similar thing to that
this is sort of nostalgic for me and i
want to continue it so no matter where
we go i appreciate you
you take care of yourself td all right
you bet thanks for the call the thomas
dimitro oh there i am
that wasn't me in michigan i don't know
where that was that's an old-school
photograph of me i actually have some
hair on the top of my head
we're looking at that right there oh so
there you go thomas dimitrov that was
his setup for the
pandemic draft right there how about
that for insight from thomas dimitrov i
like it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here